es geht los die raumfahrt macht sich auf
in ein neues zeitalter
zum ersten mal ist es gelungen eine
rakete bei einem regulären flug mit
einer wiederverwendeten ersten
raketenstufe zu starten und diese auch
wieder zurück zur erde zu bringen warum
damit jetzt ein neues zeitalter der
raumfahrt beginnt die dixie chicks unser
thema herzlich willkommen
es hat geklappt nach vielen versuchen
über die wir hier oft berichtet haben
ist es gelungen
sex up eine bereits zumal verwendete
raketenstufe zum start einer
kommerziellen mission eingesetzt und sie
auch wieder erfolgreich zur erde geholt
also kein testlauf das ist ein absolut
riesiger fortschritt und ihnen masken
firma spacex leute damit wirklich ein
neues zeitalter der raumfahrt ein
während eine station 5 rakete ende der
sechziger anfang der siebziger jahre im
staat hat damals nach heutigen maßstäben
noch eine milliarde dollar gekostet
fallen die kosten für einen raketenstart
damit auf ein historisch niedriges
niveau bei der jetzt verwendeten zelten
ein rakete sollen es 62 millionen dollar
gewesen
der start einer europäischen
ariane-5-rakete derweil immer noch 200
millionen dollar kosten also ein
riesiger unterschied gut und schön
jetzt ist die raumfahrt haid billiger
geworden aber was daran revolutioniert
ja für ihnen macht ist es nur der erste
schritt in bonn ag thi falcon heavy an
den start sie kann nicht nur das
fünffache der nutzer der folge meinen
den orbit befördern
das in mehr als 50 tonnen sie ist damit
die stärkste rakete diesem moment auf
der erde geht es ihnen macht hat mit ihr
noch hose vor ergibt deshalb auch die
nutzer für einen flug zum mars anders
und trotzdem tonnen und zum pluto das in
minimalen knapp drei tonnen
wie bitte was hat der mann vor die
besiedlung unseres sonnensystems genau
ihnen macht sagt das wäre das
sonnensystem wie siegel müssen der
aufenthalt auch nur einen planeten
weiter unsicher wie bitte moment macht
wir wollen das gesamte sonnensystem
besiedeln verkehrlich der mann hat recht
was haben in der letzten zeit mir nicht
über die verschiedensten katastrophen
richtet sie uns auf der erde drohen
akteur ihnen die klimakatastrophe super
vulkane und so weiter und so fort es
zwingend das sonnensystem zu besiedeln
wenn die menschheit überleben soll
wenn wir diese herausforderung gelöst
haben und die erde verlassen können
dann haben wir eine neue evolutionsstufe
erreicht wo ihnen macht das ist echt ein
vor den cafés der auf diese idee
gekommen ganz einfach sagte durch die
bücher von isaac asimov die habe ich
übrigens auch gelesen kann nur empfehlen
einfach hammer wie zum beispiel robert
bei audi will könnte den roman als
hörbuch kostenlos runterladen und wir
haben diesen speziellen kabel link in
der video beschreibung ansonsten gesagt
bleib dran